hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my flash episode 13 video just a
reminder that it's part one of a
two-part earth-2 episode so careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen it yet
there is a new round of the reverse
flash ring giveaway going on - now all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video the episode was so big that they
had to break it into two parts every 5
seconds there's an easter egg so let's
start with top 10 WTF and I'll just do
Easter eggs as I go through them
number 10 burying the team go through
the wormhole but it breaks the speed
cannon they have one day to fix it or
they're gonna get trapped on earth to no
surprise that they'll totally wind up
fixing it next week they'll be able to
get back because they're gonna have to
use the speed cannon to get buried to go
to National City to help Supergirl later
this year and you probably spotted at
least a couple of the Easter eggs as
they were passing through the wormhole
there was a legion flight ring that was
really what made me poop my pants
and the john wesley shipp flash Jonah
Hex who's gonna be coming on legends of
tomorrow in a couple episodes connor
hawke who were definitely gonna see on
legends of tomorrow
gorilla grodd and then Supergirl all
those things from different earths
remember they're traveling through the
multiverse so anything else they saw is
present-day
on another earth so somewhere on some
other earth john wesley shipp is still
the flash i think that's so awesome
Supergirl is on her earth we really
don't know what the designation of that
is I'm gonna call it earth 3 for now
because they're on earth 2 right now
earth 1 is the main earth of the show
the legion flight ring obviously from
present day on another earth in this
episode but I think that they're gonna
address that on legends of tomorrow like
they actually will travel to the future
at a certain point don't know if we'll
ever get to travel to those other
Earth's
but if zoom finds a way obviously he
wants more speedsters so he would try to
jump to that earth where Henry Allen
isn't still his speed - more on that
later because it doesn't sound like zoom
as a scientist but we really don't know
yet we don't have enough information
about his backstory number 9 WTF they
start running into characters from their
earth that are villains but are totally
normal on earth to talk amok is the
first one oh my god and when they say
mayor snart they're talking about
Captain Cold that's an Easter Egg for
citizen cold from flashpoint if you
never read that comic it's just an
alternate version of Captain Cold that's
good instead of being evil when cisco
and harrison wells
talk about the vibrational frequency of
the different earths you could draw a
line to crisis on Infinite Earths
and Infinite Crisis later two completely
different stories they tried to use the
vibrational frequency of different
heroes from different universes to power
this engine but I'm not not expecting to
see that anytime soon but when you
create a multiverse you tease the idea
that at some point someone is gonna try
and destroy it so that's way way off in
the distance
number eight WTF fairy meets himself and
he's a super geek just like he is on
earth one the only difference is he's
not the flash doesn't have powers and he
seems a little bit more selfish based on
what Joseph West says number seven WTF
into the police station when he walks in
and he sees the mural that says a free
and just society obviously talking about
the Justice Society because in the
comics earth-2 became the home of the
Justice Society if you're not up on your
DC Comics history the Golden Age had the
Justice Society when we got to the
Silver Age they created the Justice
League so as part of the transition from
golden to Silver Age they rebooted all
of DC's characters rematching them but
they didn't want to throw away all the
Golden Age characters so they just said
hey these guys exist on earth too and
then they had a crossover between the
Silver Age characters on earth one in
her two and you get your Justice League
Justice Society crossovers Barry is
married to iris big smooch on the lips
I'm sure that'll make a lot of you
really happy they live in their family
house the house that they grew up in
Deadshot is the police captain instead
of captain Singh his name is Deadshot
not because he is a dead shot but
because he's so terrible he couldn't hit
water if he fell out of a boat earth to
captain Singh is just a common criminal
we can talk more about Earth to iris
West in a sec because I have a feeling
that through the course of the episode
she figures out that Barry is not her
Barry she's a detective she seems really
good at her job so she's probably
figured it out like okay you are
definitely not acting like my Barry and
you know this guy who I don't know this
seems weird something's going on but on
the number six WTF Barry's mother is
still alive so there were so many
awesome things that happened while they
were in that house one you know Barry
just being awkward about iris taking her
clothes off then looking at the phone
with all the numbers on it so you
basically have half of the Justice
League here like they're all alive
somewhere Atlantis is above
Brown we knew that because jay garrick
told us we know that jay garrick is
actually friends with Arthur curry
so I'm guessing or two Barry's probably
met him two that Eddie's still alive
we have Bruce Diana and Hal Jordan the
reason I think that Clark Kent's name is
not on there is because the flash TV
show just you know in general is gonna
do the Supergirl crossover and they want
to focus more on the kara Barry
relationship then the Clark Kent Berry
relationship so they're just like if you
don't forget about Superman for just a
minute because we're gonna be focusing
on Supergirl
although Superman does exist on Kara's
world I don't know if he's gonna show up
in the crossover though I'm assuming not
so super awesome super cry worthy moment
don't mind me if I'm crying during this
phone call mom I just I just wanted
return your phone call no big deal just
gonna cry my eyes out and when his mom
makes the comment about starting to have
some grandchildren Barry and iris as
children in the comics are the tornado
twins but it gets a little timey wimey
because they live in the future because
iris is secretly from the future it gets
really complicated I don't know if we'll
ever get to see him on the show I think
it's more likely that we would see a
version of Bart Allen eventually number
five WTF still crying but crying tears
of joy because killer frost and death
storm arrived when Barry calls her
Caitlin later in the episode and she's
like I haven't heard that name in a long
time I stopped being that person it's a
very Darth Vader type moment that named
Anakin Skywalker no longer has any
meaning to me you have to remember that
Jay Garrick has been the flash for a
full year longer than Barry so
presumably for the last two years she's
been killer frost number four WTF joe
west on earth-2 is a swanky lounge
singer hates Barry and then later
iris tells our Barry that he also does
not like Joe she get that knee-jerk WTF
from Barry where he's like well they're
my family in any universe so it makes it
all that more meaningful when Barry kind
of forces the relationship between them
for number three WTF Joe West gets
killed by killer frost and death storm
they tease there was gonna be a big
death in the episode who's gonna be a
main character so most of you correctly
assumed that it would be one of the
earth two versions of a main character I
didn't think that it'd be Joe though and
as cold as Earth to Joe seemed when he
was talking to Barry he still has that
exact same type of relationship with
Iris every song is always for you baby
so it was really one of the most
touching moments in the episode
even though you also get a similar
reaction from killer frost when zoom
kills Deathstorm
so actually two main characters ended up
dying number 3 WTF Jay Garrick takes
velocity 7 getting closer to velocity 9
I'm wondering if that's gonna happen
during next week's episode or if they're
gonna tease velocity 8 and then they'll
leave velocity 9 for some future episode
I do think that they'll get to velocity
9 and that'll be part of the way that he
gets his speed back but the big WTF is
him coming clean about how he created
velocity 6 because his speed wasn't
enough for him he needed more that also
sounds a lot like what's going on with
zoom you could still try to explain zoom
is like a negative version of Jay
Garrick like the velocity 6 had some
crazy side effect that we don't know
about yet there's still a couple options
open we haven't seen the earth 2
versions of every single earth 1
character yet like we haven't seen earth
2 wallet yet so on a number two WTF zoom
kills evil Cisco who is reverb that was
just so amazing just Cisco versus evil
Cisco I can do that I will show you are
you trying to Cloud City Empire Strikes
Back me right now
most of you probably understood what
that meant but during Empire Strikes
Back
Vader told Luke we can overthrow the
Empire and rule the galaxy together
that's the offer evil Cisco made to arch
Cisco what if zoom wasn't in charge
anymore and now we know how soom knows
so much is an evil version of Cisco
who's more in command of his powers
telling him what's going on Vai being
earth one stuff but not anymore though
because he is totally dead evil Cisco is
dead so finally on my number one WTF
zoom captures Barry and puts him in a
prison right next to Jesse quick and a
mystery figure here now who's this
person in the mask if you look here it
looks like an older person just because
that their neck has some creases in it
I'm wondering if this is Barry's dad
from Earth 2 or maybe it's from earth 1
wouldn't that be a WTF if it's earth 1
Henry Allen because we really don't know
where he is right now but obviously this
is just part 1 part 2 of the episode is
called escape from Earth 2 so everybody
that survived that final attack on earth
2 is gonna band together to try and
rescue Barry Jesse quick and whoever
this mystery person is let me know in
the comments who do you think mystery
iron mask person is not just like look
at the neck and look
like an older person so I'm guessing
it's not Wally I still have a theory for
Wally as zoom but there's still a couple
possibilities I know a lot of people
want it to be Eddie but I feel like him
showing up on Barry's phone means he's a
friend
meaning that he is not zoom so let me
know what you guys think maybe you have
to watch the episode once or twice to
get a feel for it but who is the iron
mask person and who do you think zoom is
now if you haven't seen it or you missed
that video I explained the Daniel West
new 52 Wally West flash season 2 theory
in my episode 12 video from last week so
that's most of the Easter eggs in the
episode I mean they did mention jaws and
some other non comic-book stuff I don't
really consider those Easter eggs
usually an Easter egg has to be comic
book specific but let me know if you
guys spotted anything else just write it
below in the comments in related news
arrow tomorrow Merlin and Oliver are
gonna wreck the out of each other a
lot of you have also been asking about
legends of tomorrow episode 4 leaking
early
they just aired it early after the Super
Bowl in Canada but only in Canada is
airing on Thursday everywhere else that
it normally airs because they just
confirmed that Deathstroke is off-limits
to the TV show now because he is
quote-unquote booked for another
live-action project which is probably
Suicide Squad I'll do a special video
for that tomorrow before air oh wait
guys wait for that to post you can click
here for all my Super Bowl trailer
videos and you can click here to learn
all about the Deadpool sequel which they
have already greenlit like literally
just today they announced Deadpool
sequel is happening thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight